في منطقه البلقان يشتد صراع الهويه بين
صربيا وكوسوفو والذي ينذر هذه المره
بمواجهه مسلحه وفتح جبهه حرب جديده في
الخاصره الاوروبيه الضعيفه بين روسيا
والغرب
دوي اطلاق النار في كل مكان والدخان
يتعالى في شمال كوسوفو تحديدا بمدينه
الشرطه ومواطنين من العرقيه الصربيه اسفرت
عن اصابه اكثر من عشره اشخاص الخلاف
المتجذر منذ سنوات طويله في المنطقه التي
كانت وما زالت بؤره توتر استراتيجيه اخذ
منحا تصاعديا هذه المره صاحبته مطالبات
بفرض الحكم الذاتي لصالح صربيا في اعقاب
انتخابات شهدت مقاطعه لعرق السرب التوترات
والتطورات الاخيره استدعت حاله تاهب قتالي
قصوى من الجانب السلبي
قتاليه تحركت بصفه مستعجله على طول حدود
كوسوفو تحديدا المنطقه الشماليه التي تضم
لبوزافيتشان
وفق مراقبين فتحرك السيربيا الذي لم يخلو
من الرسائل المبطنه يمكن ان يعطي منعطفا
جديدا للعلاقات بعد نحو ثلاثه اشهر من
موافقه زعمي البلدين على اتفاق لتطبيع
العلاقات يدعمه الغرب فمع تقدم القوات
السربيه على الحدود واستمرار حاله التاهب
القصوى للجيش يمكن ان تتطور الاحداث لتصل
الى درجه تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه خاصه بدعم
روسي ضد الجيش الكوسوفي وقوه حفظ السلام
التي يقودها حلف شمال الاطلسي
لمتابعه
المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات